[Applause]
[Music]
let's save it for Tuesday I mean
everybody everybody has to vote so all
you stoners out there start looking for
your keys now everybody should vote we
have an election Democrats have been
voting by mail make sure there's enough
stamps on your thing and Republicans
same goes for your bombs we found out
this week I was on the list so I was
nominated but don't ask me who's gonna
win you know what vote and make us win
can we stop pretending that the polls
are a good indicator of what people are
gonna do and how they're gonna vote our
elections aren't even a good indicator
of people's votes but there is a good
omen I think there's a good omen
yesterday the Republicans lost Kayne
[Applause]
he must be back on his meds he said he
picked weeded out I now realize I've
been used to spread a message but I
don't believe it and King told him he
doesn't have to sleep on the couch
anymore I think this is our formula for
deep programming Republicans one part
paxil two parts badonkadonk
that's oh and Oprah's on the campaign
trail that's pretty powerful boy went
door-to-door for Stacey Abrams in
Georgia when knocking on doors imagine
that
Oprah comes to your door so far she's
convinced five women to vote for Abrams
and two men to put the shotgun down
thank you ma'am
laughing where you should I appreciate
by the way all of you putting on such a
brave face when you I'm sure know that
we're only days away from being
overtaken by a migrant caravan I mean
they are beating this story like whitey
bulger in prison
I mean every day it gets worse Trump is
like a racist Paul Revere you know the
migrants are coming the migrants are
coming I don't get this the migrants are
the ones living off Mexican food and
we're the ones [ __ ] in our pants he
keeps calling it an invasion yes an
invasion of strollers yes the great
invaders of history Attila the Hun Ivan
the Terrible Dora the Explorer every day
FoxNews treats us like it's the exam B
apocalypse but zombies eat brains why
would they be heading toward America
we Trump ascending troops the army to
stare down the people with sippy cups
III mean I don't want to say the army is
being used as props but instead of move
out the commanding officer now says
places places everyone
got to give it at Donald Trump he sticks
to the message boy he said the other day
oh just caravan a lot bigger then people
think and then I swear to god I'm not
making us happy said and I'm pretty good
at estimating crowd size
next to modesty it's one of my greatest
gifts I'm also a war hero with a 32-inch
waist who enjoys reading and helping
poor people no Trump get this guy he
keeps complaining that the mail bomber
and the synagogue shooter have heard his
election momentum that's his gripe these
real attacks are taking attention away
from my made-up attack how's the guy
supposed to stir up hatred for Democrats
and Jews when all the media reports is
attacks on Democrats and Jews
every day he somehow finds a way to go
lower even just in this one week or two
you know first saying that there are
terrorists in the caravan calling an
invasion calling out the troops the army
tried to revoke birthright Sedition such
and then yesterday the worst of all
saying anyone who throws a rock will be
treated as if they have a rifle let me
tell you something if there was a
teenager from Central America right now
who could throw a rock that fast and
that hard he'd be in the Dodgers farm
system already